u.s president donald trump says he will
not mandate face coverings nationwide
to slow the spread of the coronavirus
trump says the public should be free to
decide whether to wear them or not
he made the comments to fox news as the
u.s recorded more than 70 thousand new
infections
for a second consecutive day that's the
highest number of daily cases
since the beginning of the pandemic
[Music]
as the virus marches on in the u.s
public health professionals are begging
people to wear masks and abide by social
distancing rules
florida alone recorded over 11 000 cases
on friday
with california texas and arizona
following closely behind
the nation's top infectious diseases
expert had this message
i can say as a public health official
that i would urge
the leaders the local political and
other leaders
in states and cities and towns
to be as forceful as possible
in getting your citizenry to wear masks
contact tracing is no longer possible in
the worst affected areas because daily
infection rates are so high
many politicians including florida's
republican governor ron desantis
are adamant about avoiding another
shutdown relying instead on increased
testing to bring the virus
under control but with intensive care
units in the state filling to capacity
it's already too late for that and
health care workers
will have to shoulder the burden of
being unable
to save many lives ndw correspondent
chef on siemens
is in miami us stefan we're seeing grim
new figures what's the situation like in
miami
situation is grim and as much as the
figures are
today another 11 000 new corona virus
infection cases
that's massive yesterday 15 000.
florida as a state has 20 percent more
new corona virus cases
than arizona 70 more than texas
double the amount of california so this
is the absolute red zone here this is
the worst case scenario
uh in the last four weeks and for
florida
remember just a few months ago and this
is like groundhog day here
um it was this governor in this state
which came late to the game they closed
down late and they opened early
and people forgot to wear this or were
complacent and didn't think it was
necessary to wear this
mess we're back to masks to basics wear
a mask when you're outside when you're
inside
and tracing and testing testing testing
testing
none of this has happened here within
the last few months and this
explains why the numbers in florida are
so staggeringly high
dangerously high because now tracing is
not even possible anymore
because the infection rates are daily so
high
so what are you seeing there on the
ground how seriously are residents
actually taking the pandemic precautions
i think they're beginning again to get a
grip of how
dangerous and precare this whole
situation for them is the
mayor of miami-dade county issued now
a a mandatory mask order
for outside and inside so that means
people in miami are supposed to wear a
mask when they're outside
doing their business out and about and
inside
but of course how do you enforce this
that's really really hot there's
millions of people living
in florida of course and then millions
of those here in miami
it is impossible to enforce this and i
have to say so from what we say
it's about 50 50 we see a lot of people
wearing masks but we see an equal amount
of people who just don't care
or don't seem to care at least for
whatever reason that is
so give us a little bit of a bigger
picture in florida what exactly is the
state government proposing to do
to get infection rates under control
well very good question we talked to two
doctors today and they said they
basically
begged us as a as a a
transmitter to the public here in
america and around the world
please wear masks please wear a mask
even if politicians don't agree on what
to do
and the governor he has said he's not
going to go back to shut down anything
so he's adamant about leaving things as
they are
opting upping testing upping
healthcare workers and their support ppe
and what have you
even the army is here with personnel
helping testing stations and so on but a
shutdown is not going to happen here so
what happens here is all on the
shoulders of medica
of healthcare professionals and they are
begging people to
practice social distancing and wear
masks to
flatten the curve because that has not
happened here
and that was dw correspondent stefan
simons reporting from miami uh stefan
stay healthy
you